treason shall never go unpunished
sir ellen bring me his head
um
leave one wolf alive and the sheep are
never
safe
[Music]
when people ask you what happened here
thousand the north remembers
tell them winter came for house frey
for the watch
[Music]
next time you think about naked girls
when you feel an itch
my father won the real war he killed
prince rhaegar
he took the crown while you hid on a
castley rock
the king is tired see him to his
chambers come along lord tyrion was kind
he was gentle he never touched me
you're not lying to me no my lord
that would be a bad way to start a
marriage
we're man and wife now we should be
honest with each other
don't you think yes
[Music]
and she loved him
[Music]
he's never been a bastard
he's the heir to the iron throne all you
needed to do was climb the steps
yourself
such a sad mistake i've made many
mistakes in my life
that wasn't one of them oh but it was
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die
there is no middle ground i'm sorry
i'm so sorry don't be
all i've ever wanted was to serve you
i'll always love you
i command you to heal yourself
and then return to me when i take the
seven kingdoms
[Music]
i need you by my side
[Music]
uh
you lead the seven kingdoms to the best
of your abilities from this day
until your last day
[Music]
why do you think i came all this way